نعم في هذا الموقع الذي يوجد فيه نعم يمكن
القول ان هناك عمليات الانتشار الجثث لكن
مع الاسف قبل ان نكون معكم واثناء تحضيرنا
لهذا المباشر طلبت منا الشرطه عدم تصوير
فرق الانقاذ وهي تقوم بازاله الجثث قبل
قبل حوالي 20 دقيقه وعندما كنا في هذا
المكان
انتشل انتشر احد فرق الانقاذ احدى الجثث
والان كما اشاهد هم يحضرون انتشار جثه
اخرى لذلك سابقى يعني سنحترم رغبه الشرطه
التركيه ونقوم برصد هذا المشهد هنا هم
يحاولون الان انتشار جثه اخرى لكن ساحاول
رصد هذا المشهد هنا في مدينه الاصلاحيه في
غازي عنتاب كما تشاهدين حجم الدمار الكبير
في هذا الشارع وهذا الحي الى الامام هناك
ايضا
الابنيه المهدمه هذا كان احد الطرق
الرئيسيه او هو الطريق الرئيسي الذي كان
في منطقه اصلاحيه في ولايه غازي عنتاب هذا
الطريق القديم الذي كان يربط او الطريق ما
بين عفوا ولايتي غازي عنتاب وهاتاي هذا
الطريق القديم الذي كان يخترق المدينه من
في وسط المدينه او يمر في وسط المدينه كما
نشاهد دمار كبير جدا في هذا الطريق طبعا
عمليات ازاله الانقاض في ذلك المبنى حيث
الاليه
ربما اذا كانت تظهر على الشاشه الاليات
هناك تزيد الركام بعد انتهاء عمليات البحث
وبالتالي
هناك بعض المباني انتهت بالفعل عمليات
البحث من قبل فراق الانقاذ وحاليا فقط
الجرافات هي من تقوم بجرف الركام في
محاوله لازاله اكوام الكتل الخرسانيه
الموجوده في هذه المدينه